I would wake up my wife in the middle of  the night because I would dream of  submission I will put her in the  submission and I would ask her when her  oh swear to God come here honey for a  second okay that won't work babe it's  your shoulder right yeah she said my  shoulder and we'll write it down and the  next day  we'll be serious about this 100 this  this happened a bunch of times people  walk in the kitchen and I said lean over  and I would I'd go for a joke and say  are you getting dizzy or does it hurt  your throat she said I'm getting this  you guys see it's a blood joke you know  so I but I became obsessed with it the  whole house was a little Post-its but I  never lost a fight anymore  you know I lost my last fight by way of  submission and I won my next eight  fights by submission people were  freaking out in Japan to go what's going  on